[Music]
today we're checking out everything that
humanity hope is done in this village
including this community sitter in front
of me here hopefully soon it has Wi-Fi
to connect with the world beyond
Honduras Bachelor Ben Higgins and
fiancee Lauren Bushnell headed to
Honduras this month to help humanity and
hope the nonprofit Ben has worked with
for years he even wore a bracelet to
support the organization during The
Bachelor and this trip he brought Lauren
along for the first time at one of
meeting hopes original villages behind
us the grand farm is 40 acres of
plantains and corn this farm is expected
in the next two years become our first
the cropland project which means that
year every years and those will be able
to adopt this and make money and then
start investing in their own communities
Ben actually met with another special
lady while in Honduras this is Miss
Piggy
she is my beautiful sister that my mom
purchased about four months ago Miss
Piggy here will now provide babies just
for us of submarket I've never had a
sibling in my life so Miss Piggy's my
first